In some ways it's the women that are
embracing the masculine archetype in
some ways that are being successful.
I mean they're.
They're being extraordinarily
responsible and they're.
They're feeling a lot of these positions
quicker than men can.
I mean they're and they're graduating at
higher rates of college and they're
declining.
They're declining motherhood or they're
at least suspending it throughout the
west,
which is you could argue for either
ways.
There's reasons for that,
but I guess my question is,
well,
I think that the expression of the
masculine spirit in women isn't
denigrated,
like women don't get accused of
contributing to the patriarchy even when
they take positions in society that you
would think are fully patriarchal now
and which is a strange thing.
So women who go to law school and then
and then practice as corporate lawyers
say,
aren't subject to the same.
What would you call it?
Claim that their activity is
facilitating that.
The decline of the planet.
I guess because they're seen as well,
they're there because of their gender.
I suppose they're seen as as as leaders
of the rebellion against the patriarchal
spirit.
Even though structurally it boils down
to the same thing,
sure,
so that masculine,
classically masculine,
symbolically masculine,
yearning for hierarchical productivity
and competition is rewarded in women but
not in men and which is also a very
perverse thing because it doesn't make
any sense.
It makes sense through the
postmodernists view,
which is they're just undoing the
oppressor ship of the man and the last
one,
hundred 50 years.
So the ends justify the means.
That's the way they look at it.
Whatever power women can take from men
is a good thing.
That's the way they look at it.
Well,
there's a funny thing about that too,
that like I,
I read this in 12 rules for life.
I was looking at some of the Pew
Research Data and I don't remember the
figures precisely,
but over the last 15 years,
the percentage of women who young women
who claim that they would like to be
married in a permanent relationship has
gone up a substantial amount.
I don't remember what it was,
a 50 percent approximately springs to
mind,
but a lot at the same time.
It's declined almost the same degree
among young men and so what's.
What's perverse about this,
this is something I've talked to my
daughter a fair a bit about is that I
mean if you ask young women what they
want,
I don't know if they can answer because
I don't know if they know if they're 19
or 20 because I think their heads are so
muddled by what they've been told that
they don't really know,
but my sense is that women want the
opportunity to develop their career in
whatever direction they see fit and fair
enough,
but they want an intimate relationship
and usually a monogamous one that's
permanent and they want to have the
opportunity to have kids and what you
see happening.
Inevitably,
and I believe this to be the case.
I've watched very carefully as I've,
as I've grown up and got older because
I've worked with women my whole life,
is that women are less,
are less compelled by their career as
they approach their thirties and more
compelled by the desire to have a
permanent relationship and biological
too.
I would argue to.
No,
I mean,
I,
I think it's,
it's a biological necessity because
women have to have children relatively
young.
That's correct.
But it's interesting to watch it
phenomenologically and even the women
that I've seen who've had very high
powered careers is that as they move
into their,
especially their early thirties,
they start to realize that the career is
a pretty one dimensional enterprise,
even if it's a good career,
because even good careers are still jobs
and good careers.
They're also very hard jobs.
They're like 70 hour a week jobs and
they're full bore commitment jobs and to
figure out how to have a career like
that and to have a life,
to have a family,
to have an intimate relationship,
to have children and then to also be
able to take care of them.
That's a very complex,
um,
that's a very complex job to manage.
And so what's strange is,
I think what's strange is that the very
things that the radicals are undermining
the monogamous family are actually those
things that women most want,
especially as they approach their
thirties.
And so this is a catastrophe on both
ends of the,
of the gender distribution.